in the writing and development process
what kinds of questions were you
asking yourself about the story about
the characters
um in my writing process i actually
i have a weird process i've read this
book called the mind of the maker by
dorothy l sayers and it's a fascinating
book i recommend to anybody in the
creative
field she wrote in 19 1941 it came out
and she was a mystery writer but she
wrote this one it was about she's trying
to write a book of theology
but in trying to explain the mind of of
a god
she uses artists and writers as an
example
and it's one of the things i loved about
it is she said that as a creator
you create the world you create the
physics of it and the laws of it and you
create the people that inhabit it
but then you give them free will and
to me that is the most organic form of
writing and so
my writing process is i try to i try to
just see the world and try to understand
it and know who my characters are and
the premise
and then i literally just i ferment on
that for a while until i feel like i
have an understanding i'll write notes
and stuff like that
and then i literally just sit down and
write
and just when it comes to a plot point
like what would they do here what would
they do here
and letting the character i've conjured
my mind have that free will to make
those choices instead of me guiding them
and the only time i feel like i hit a
writer's block now
is when i'm trying to force them to do
something they wouldn't do
and so that is kind of my writing
process and then once i have a first
draft
out that's when i then go back and start
asking myself those questions like okay
here are some of the themes i wanted to
address
that maybe aren't as clear or in it how
do i put that into it how do i
is there a way place where this works is
there a place where this works
um and so i have a kind of a weird
writing style i developed after reading
that book and
it was to me it was a lifesaver because
that's why fray ended up being the film
it is was
i completely after reading that i
changed my whole creative
style and writing style based on what
i'd read in there
and uh um it obviously worked with frey
uh so i decided to keep doing it that
way and um
you know i think that's part of why
blood from stone is so different
as well is i don't set up a structure i
don't set up markers i don't have any
plot points i write down
it's like here's the world here's the
characters let's see where we go
and i actually like the process now
um i can like fray i wrote in about
three weeks beginning to end and the
first draft of the final draft
there's a lot of editing a lot of
refining but
as a whole they're very similar and same
with blood from stone
if you look at the first draft in the
final draft other than chopping a lot of
pages off of it it's a very similar
story
uh so for better for worse the writing
style that works for me we'll see what
audiences feel but i enjoy it i
comes out much more organically i don't
get writer's block
it just takes a lot longer to write that
first page because you're trying to
figure out
all the aspects of the world that
they're in all the people
that are there but once you have that
all
just kind of let them loose in your
brain and see what happens that's how i
do it at least
how did you find that book or how did
the book find you it sounds like that
sounds like a very magical book i
haven't actually heard of it
it's yeah i found it i one of my
obsessions
is i collect old books
uh not like collectible old books i only
have a few of those
but just i love going into antique
stores thrift stores old bookstores
and digging through for just ones that
sound interesting and
i'm obsessed with reading about
psychology i'm obsessed with reading
about religion and theology
um i'm obsessed with reading about other
cultures um
and uh anthropology and all that sort of
stuff and i just
i was going through one of those
sections there was a book called the
mind of the maker i'm like
well that sounds fascinating and i read
just the first two pages of
her of dorothy's uh introduction
and i was laughing like it is hilarious
she the first two pages of it are just
brilliant it goes on i mean throughout
it she's actually funny she has an
entire chapter
i really feel like it was devoted to
just trashy and another author she hated
every time she is using examples of
creative blasphemy
she references his work and just trashes
him
she's absolutely hilarious in the book
it's a really thoughtful book a really
heavy book it's also a motivating one
because she wrote it during world war
ii and twice in the book she briefly
references
getting back to writing after a bombing
raid
and i think back to that whenever i've
had a bad day and i just don't feel like
being creative i'm like
she wrote one of my favorite books while
being bombed by nazis
i can get over my bad day and write
so it's just all around i highly
recommend that book if you can track it
down
you